hi I'm Erik Bosse Game of Thrones season
8 opens with a totally new opening title
sequence that is so packed with Easter
eggs admissible clues that I had to make
a separate thing breaking it all down
now my goal was to do this within the 1
minute 40 seconds that the sequence
actually lasts but you know it takes
time to explain things and why they're
actually more important than the job
you're supposed to be doing right now oh
look at you clicking over to another tab
sorry your boss already saw you in
today's your last day
great unemployment more time to obsess
over Game of Thrones so like in last
season's these opening titles open with
the image of the astrolabe of the
Citadel with tableaus that depicts key
events in the history of Westeros but
whereas before these events included the
doom of Valyria Robert's rebellion and
Robert's ascension to the iron throne
this final season opening title sequence
depicts an updated history of Westeros
so now the astrolabe depicts the
destruction of the wall by Viz Ariane
blowing open a crevasse and setting the
whole wall ablaze beneath the dragon is
the army of the Dead and fleeing the
wall are these flocks of birds
representing the birds through which
brand start warped and witnessed the
knight king's destruction now over the
years these opening credits have been
designed by the elastic creative team
led by angus wall and kirk shintani they
said that the convergence of all the
characters in season 8 allowed them to
avoid having to speed past a ton of
scattered locations and reorient the
viewer and instead explore two or three
locations in greater depth they wanted
to keep the map of Westeros looking like
a model someone from within the world of
the show would conceivably build
themselves kind of like an 8-bit
Minecraft aesthetic but now they could
build out this map with more accuracy in
detail so after the astrolabe the first
location we see is the wall blown open
at eastwatch-by-the-sea as it was in the
final shots of season 7 this is the most
significant Geographic transformation of
the map of Westeros in thousands of
years this wall was built 8,000 years
ago by bran the Builder after the end of
the war between the children of the
forest and the first men a war that led
to the creation of the night King and
the White Walkers the children of the
forest shattered the arm of Dorne the
land bridge connecting Westeros and
Essos to keep out the invading Andals
that event was the last major change of
the geography of Westeros in the wall
which was built by the men to do the
same thing to the White Walkers keep
them out is now gone Westeros
is back open for the plundering this
sequence shows the progress of the White
Walkers by flipping over these tiles
from white to a bluish black color from
snow to ice the designers wanted to
evoke classic strategy games like risk
which moves game pieces around to show
armies on the move and that leads to the
White Walkers first stop after the wall
last hearth the northernmost castle in
the seat of house unburn now the shape
of the mound that the castle sits upon
is a spiral a clue hinting at the
pattern of the knight king's massacre of
the umbers and young Ned umber
recreating the spiral imagery of the
knight Kings origin now episode one
seems like the last we'll see of last
heart and we will see new little changes
to the opening titles of episodes 2
through 6 so I'll keep track of them in
future episodes after last hearth we
move on to Winterfell which this
sequence now gives us a ground view of
first there's the weirwood tree in the
godswood and unlike past seasons the
tree now blooms with lush amounts of red
leaves this could be a reflection of all
the surviving Starks back under one roof
finally we're the fact that brand the
three-eyed raven who has a spiritual
connection with the weirwood trees bran
is essentially a tree boy who stalks can
now see wider and further than ever
before then we glide into the interior
of the Great Hall it assembles with
gears and cogs and levers kind of like
the inside of a clock a steampunk
Leonardo da Vinci design in order to
keep all these new building edifice is
consistently sized the design team made
them to scale of a man of six feet in
height then down into the crypts where
we briefly passed the Statue of Lyanna
stark the location of John's critical
revelation in episode 1 now since past
opening sequences were lit by the
burning Sun these dark crypts inside
presented a lighting problem so they lit
the crypts by torchlight and the
designers cast a flickering light
movement on all the surfaces next the
astrolabe shows us another major
historical event the red wedding this is
set at the twins the decapitated stark
direwolf hangs from a noose the darvis
bodies filled with arrows and a dagger
and its back just as Robb Stark was
murdered a Lannister lion bears down
with a Tully fish in its mouth for Tywin
Lannister's victory over Catelyn and the
rest of the Tully's and a Bolton flayed
man holds the direwolf severed head for
Roose Bolton's role
and helping orchestrate this
assassination our final destination is
King's Landing but just north of it in
the Riverlands is the God's eye lake
known for the mysterious Isle of faces
in the middle which is an uninhabited
island that contains a grove of weirwood
trees this was the location the children
of the forest formed the pact with the
first men some believed this is the
location the night king was created no
one knows much more about the island
because it's just maintained by a sacred
order called the green men who wrote out
to the island they ride Elks some
believe that they have antlers or horns
themselves and they have dark green skin
you know maybe they're out there having
sex with those tree faces hey no one can
prove me wrong but interestingly in
these titles the Isle of faces isn't an
island in the lake it's connected to the
mainland
it's a peninsula could this tiny change
mean the Isle of faces could be a place
two characters visit a possible
destination of the night King and maybe
his aim is to return to his origin point
and exterminate any remaining children
forced who live there along with their
you know groundskeeper Willy's and
they're confirmed tree fetishes but then
to King's Landing which is now laid out
as a massive city with a huge population
the foundation of the Sept of Baelor is
visible but it doesn't rise with the
rest of the structures because you know
when boom boom the shots of the castle
show the map floor courtyard that Cersei
had installed last season the camera
zooms down the Tower of the hand and its
spiral staircase perhaps this spiral is
another nod to the night king mr. spiral
and maybe a clue that he could stage a
similar massacre with human flesh there
down into the dungeons below is the
scorpion the giant crossbow weapon that
Qyburn design and bran used on Danny and
drogon last season the scorpion is aimed
at the dragon's skull of balerion the
dread
Aegon the conquerors dragon perhaps this
is another clue that Braun who was
equipped with the smaller crossbow for a
different purpose in the season premiere
well once again aim this surface-to-air
defense at a dragon maybe this time a
zombie dragon but then back up to the
red keep the Iron Throne Rises with
Circe's Lannister lion and the window
behind it but again all of this movement
is connected to a vast network of gears
evoking Daenerys his description of the
cycle of power as a giant wheel a wheel
that she intends to break and that wheel
frames the final title
with the dragon lion stag and direwolf a
wheel that could simply break leaving
none of these houses in power but right
before that title the astrolabe shows
one last event a large dragon with three
smaller dragons beneath a comet facing a
bowing row of horses so this big dragon
is Daenerys and the three smaller ones
are her dragons drogon rhaegal and
Viserion the moment of their birth at
the end of the first season before the
bow in Dothraki who are represented by
horses now the inclusion of the comet is
interesting because that didn't appear
during the first reveal of the Dragons
it didn't show up until the beginning of
season 2 after their arrival many
interpreted the comet as a sign of the
Dragons returned the world and perhaps
the return of magic in general or maybe
it really was the bleeding star of the
Ozora hi princess or princess that was
promised prophecy rendering Daenerys
Targaryen here as that prophesied hero
but I'm curious to know from you guys
what do you think the night Kings final
destination will be the Isle of faces or
the Iron Throne comment down below with
your thoughts and follow me on instagram
and twitter at EI vas and again these
opening titles will likely evolve in
little ways episode 2 episode so be sure
to check out my weekly scene-by-scene
breakdowns for all the new clues as they
emerge you can find them by subscribing
the new rock stars on YouTube and
subscribing to our podcast feed Westeros
weekly if you haven't already to get
early access to all of our Game of
Thrones coverage thank you for watching
and sorry for getting me fired
[Music]